since you think there's aliens out there
and
you're somebody that's thought about war
quite a bit do you think alien
civilizations when we meet them would
want war
would would they be a danger to us would
they be a friend to us
what's your intuition
about intelligences out there
my intuition tells me that when two
people like yourself and myself or
anyone get together
often the output is greater than
individuals
and when we work together we can
typically do things
that are more impressive and better than
if a single person works alone
and now i know that
war has
driven technology technological
progress
but perhaps there's other mechanisms
that can do so
but regardless
i wonder you know if we truly think
about an advanced society that has been
perhaps thousands or millions of years
ahead of us
i would imagine that same
same truth to be there that people
working together creatures working
together is a good thing for
society or its society as a whole
and if we consider that
as
we imagine a society growing and
expanding
in a sense the ultimate
output of a planet could only be
achieved in some senses if everyone was
working towards the same goal and there
might be
you know wonders and secrets and things
that we can't imagine just simply
because of time frames that we we live
under and we think in
but if a a planet has a single unit and
it almost as an entity itself at a
certain level right if everything's
working towards the same output you know
i could almost imagine an intelligent
species that approached us planted the
planet instead of person to person
because that's how they've evolved and
they've assumed any intelligent species
would understand that working together
is better than not
um and so you know my heart tells me
that at a certain point
um you know love and caring and desire
to work together is much more powerful
than you know the technological progress
that war would bring
you